one hand of the snake is russia one hand
of the snake is the west
beautiful place thank you there's a lot
of craft in here i'm going to show you
something up here
the biggest danger in ukraine
it's like my wife when i saw her on the
street once
alright guys today's video is about
keep the most mixed up city in europe
and so what we're gonna do is well
hopefully i don't crash this thing
it's sort of hard to film and ride but
what we're gonna do
is cruise around and i'll bring you to
some of my
favorite places and well you can feel it
for yourself
the contrasts that exist in this very
cool city
[Music]
all right before we get started i've got
to get a little snack i really like this
store it's a small health food store
and also i forgot to mention in this
video uh we're gonna go to all these
places
and i've lived here roughly almost four
years
so i want to talk about what i've seen
what i've learned and just basically
outside observations of living in
keep ukraine
very sweet nice people here in this shop
they do it well so whatever what i've
found to be true in this
in this city is businesses are either
done really well
like this one great customer service
good product
or just horribly terrible customer
service you're like a
criminal walking in a store like you've
done something wrong but you're only
there to purchase something
so it really works in the extremes in
that regard okay let's go to
uh the first destination coming up here
on landscape
alley and this is a great place just to
walk relax not crash
on these bolt things this is what i'm
riding
and look at that beautiful mural and the
snake
one hand of the snake is russia one hand
of the snake is the west
and i don't know what uh character that
is but
sword in the middle everyone let go of
me
that's what that means here we go an old
building they're
making something new out of that they're
taking some of the old reinforcing it
and uh putting a new structure up there
so you have a lot of this in kiev a lot
of little pathways
walkways you got these things now
these just came in last month so
a lot of changes in my short time here a
lot of these businesses in kiev just
well there's a bookstore out of a little
truck
uh coffee shops all sorts of things
this was just built this infrastructure
here this area they've really made
a lot nicer and i don't want to give too
much credit to the city
because while these are great
improvements the big things like uh air
quality
is something the city has completely
neglected 100
but this stuff does show on the surface
it does make the city nicer
for sure that's a new stairway roughly
roughly a year ago this is the old city
this is where
i like the best i think this is the um
most charming guts has the most feel to
it the most texture
and now we're looking out here to
lissagora
which is which is mountain out there
where those people are
a lot of pagan rituals out there a lot
of i've heard satanic rituals too
all sorts of [ __ ] happening and then out
across the river that's the left bank
whole other
side of the city we're not going to go
to today i think they're the most
beautiful
types of churches this is a baroque
style
when i first came here about the first
year i'd said
wow unbelievable now somewhat used to
them but they're still
like still definitely stand out as this
iconic architecture
[Music]
what i love is the collection of old and
new here so that place we just went by
you couldn't see inside but it's a nice
modern cool restaurant called kasatka
good food and then
some stuff's falling apart then some
stuff's new
and then you have stuff like this which
has not changed since i moved here
roughly four years ago let's check out
this
very cool haunted looking building
up here where is it vacant
old there are probably some
homeless people living in there and it's
not like it's the only one
they're all over the place so you have
that architecture
and then you have brand new modern
architecture
and they can be right next to each other
not in this part of the city but in
other parts
i feel this place is very creative very
creative in its businesses so
ukrainians are willing to try new things
that are not
let's say in their culture and so here
we have a restaurant called zigzag
and i love the design in here it's got a
great vibe
a lot of people out dining on the street
i don't know if the mask rule is on or
no it doesn't look like it
very nice interior spaces here look at
these window sills
very cool style
and so when i compare to other parts of
europe
i need to when i compare to other parts
of europe
for example italy just got back from
italy
and i was in the city of trieste which
is 300 000.
there isn't i couldn't find anything
like that and
i find a lot of european countries
western european countries not
everywhere but a lot
um they have their traditions and the
way they do things
right so the italians you know we have
italian food it's the best food we've
always done it this way we're always
going to do it this way
and why would you change up that recipe
where in ukraine
people are willing to experiment more
willing to try new things i think a lot
of it has to do with the fact that
you know nobody wants to go back to
soviet times like they don't want to go
back in their history let's say their
recent history
they want to move forward and where i
feel like countries
i'm being very over generalistic here
about countries like france
or italy you know they have something
they really hold on to
deeply and they want to stick to that
and are less willing
to experiment try and fail another
example of that is i was just in
budapest hungary and it's part of the eu
hungary's wealthier than ukraine but way
less of that
way less of these new interior spaces
more of a hold on to the past
hey there's nothing wrong with that it's
just an observation here i'm going to
show you something up here
that's uh the biggest danger
in ukraine i'm serious this is
definitely the biggest danger
in kiev for sure
i want to show you this building here
not the most beautiful looking building
right
but check it out you're going to see
something different up here it's like a
ship
very beautiful example of constructivism
beauty isn't that i behold it for sure
but i love that thing
all right here's the most dangerous uh
thing you'll encounter in the city
most likely check it out these balconies
and see how they're flaking apart
well all over the city see that one see
the brick behind it
all over the city uh you'll see uh ropes
coming out
and marking people off of where not to
walk
because that stuff falls down
i've seen it happen i've heard it happen
and that's just a matter of luck so
instead of fixing the old buildings they
put up these fences
and this basically catches anything that
falls from above pieces of stone
someone's laundry other various things
so watch where you walk
and watch where you step to
i never had a fear of stepping on a
culvert because
you know the round lid can't fall in
wrong the whole structure around it
might be decayed
and that the whole thing will go down
above
below in the soviet elevators
biggest dangers in kiev
a great example of cave contrast you
have these old balcons
balconies and then this new
thai restaurant with an excellent
outdoor
seating scene
and here's an example of freedom here
going down a one-way road the wrong way
i'm on a scooter
uh i wouldn't do this at all people
would
society wouldn't be okay with it let's
say here
nobody cares about that stuff right as
long as you're not in the way
there are really no rules in that
respect
so here we go here's a place that i love
we have this
new relatively new vietnamese restaurant
great place a velo track
like when's the last time a velo track
was built in this world someone correct
me if i'm wrong here
i used to ride these things as a kid
so i love velo tracks and this one i
believe was completed
right when i moved here four years ago
and then behind
you have these apartment towers you can
see this one is
incomplete i don't think really anyone's
living in this one and the story i heard
was
that the developer built most of the way
and then bounced out of town and so you
hear of that a lot
where people are putting a deposit on
apartment buildings
that have not been completed they'll get
a cheaper sale price if they do so
and the developer bounces goes to
western europe with his kids
calls it a day there's a lot of that
corruption unfortunately
which is very savage
one of the pros here is the tightness
the connectivity in the culture now
strangers to strangers it's more of a
distant place i think america is much
more open to saying hi to someone you
don't know
or or befriending someone to a point um
with very little background together but
here's more about
you know the family going out to the
park you know
long-standing friends meeting up so you
definitely
even though i'm not from here i feel
that vibe and it's very attractive
it's very cool falling apart but cool
design
okay let's step into this part here
two
[Music]
this is one of the nicest parks in the
city chevron park
and you'll see in a second these very
cool chairs they have set up
this is a saturday but it is like this
there we go
i love that setup this is a saturday but
it is like this
most days most nice days
okay one of the things i do uh love and
both hate about the culture is
well i love the fact that there is this
you know
creepy weirdos around just
normal people having a a nice time
together relaxing
uh but what sometimes when you're trying
to get things
done and be a little more efficient
in life well this can be a bit a bit
annoying
for example uh being on time
uh moving beyond theory into action
sometimes is uh slow i'm not saying all
the time
uh there's some people doing some
amazing things here
but in general if i'm gonna compare the
cultures between the us
and ukraine us is more efficient more
more go go go
ukraine has more of this so depending on
your lifestyle and what you like
you want to accomplish a lot of things a
little harder here
if you want to enjoy time with your
friends
at being out not rushing around you feel
how there's like
zero anxiety in this mix it seems quite
quite relaxed well it is
a lot of new towers going up in the city
like this
i don't know who's moving in all these
new places
i don't i don't have direct evidence but
people have told me you know a lot of
city officials make money off bribes and
this and that
and so you're putting a lot of towers up
in an old city with old
infrastructure and people are having
water problems they're having
electrical problems sewer problems all
this sort of stuff
and that's what happens when you don't
have any rules
or the rules are just for the you know
the government officials and the mafioso
types
which is the case all right i want to
show you one other example of what i'm
talking about
of architecture look at this collection
you have this old
early 20th century building you have
this new guy
then you have this stalinca
you know from stalinist times you have
this new one new one behind
the tower we just went by all on top of
each other
well as people just park on the
sidewalks uh this is quite common
usually the nicer the car the more of an
ass someone is meaning
they'll put it like closer to the stairs
more in the way this is a place called
lift 99 co-working space and i was here
last year
i was here for a few months there are a
lot of these co-working spaces now in
kiev
you do you work here do you work here
oh handing them you guys run this place
[Laughter]
cool thank you so
here we have lift 99 and this is a
co-working space a very beautiful
co-working space they did an excellent
job with design so what's up with the
pandemic is nobody coming here or what
it's saturday oh it's saturday too like
90 people per day here
90 per day yeah yeah so it's fun
yeah well an example i want to make
maybe you can
relate to this in ukraine many times the
outside is different than the inside
right so outside in the streets
sometimes things might be broken
or you know something off but you go in
some of these spaces and they're amazing
right
you would never know that it's here that
it's here yeah
yeah it's like my wife
when i saw her on the street once uh she
looks so
serious and stoic almost scary
she's ukrainian and i'm like whoa and
then oh well that's that's natalia
that's my wife
and so she's the warmest most loving
coolest person
but sometimes she puts on this like you
know
out in public this uh this image
yeah so i think it's a metaphor for
oftentimes the people
and the building spaces not always
but there's a lot inside here there's a
lot of beauty
inside once doors open up once people
open up
uh really one of the the strong points
of this culture
a lot of people here don't like this
stuff because it's a it's a reminder of
the past
but ah it's it's a ship you see that at
the top looks like a big uh the top of a
big tanker
i get it soviet architecture is not for
everyone but check out
this building behind me it's such
a cool ahead of its time
yellow
since i came here uh i'd say
the level of english on the streets has
increased by
50 percent with the young people at
least so many people
speak english now and when i first got
here
uh practically nobody i mean it was very
sparingly
which is my fault you know i got to
speak the language if i'm in a
in their country but it's changed a lot
it's changed because
just in this short amount of time uh
ukrainians are allowed to go to schengen
countries which are basically all
western european countries
in the eu without a visa before that
time
they needed a visa to go it was a big
process then before covert
there were all these flights that were
coming in here so it's super easy to get
to italy or france or wherever
and so a lot of the young people started
traveling and they'd go and they'd come
back
excited on their trips and discoveries
and
that i think has changed some of the
energy in the city also
and that's that's only been the last
three years
where ukrainians have allowed been
allowed to do that
continuing with the theme of contrast we
have these old apartment blocks
a catholic cathedral
and then to our left this
new modern contemporary
architecture there's a nice restaurant
up there
and then a coffee shop down here
a very good coffee shop it's called one
life
so i was talking about creativity
earlier
this is a restaurant that's quite new
beautiful windows nice marble floor
tile work oh is there elsewhere today
you have such a beautiful place thank
you there's a lot of
craft in here thank you look at this
staircase spiral staircase
with this pattern in the middle a very
cool floor
and this tile work that is not it's not
cheap labor that takes some time to do
marble bar what's up man who's your
officer too
wow so beautiful guys thank you very
much all right
ciao that's it i absolutely love this
door
and then we have going out into the
cathedral
in this place called one love this is a
great place just to come by
grab a book a lot of good books on art
history
and uh spend an afternoon
nice desserts coffees tea
[Music]
we've got a lot of nice cars around here
new towers i think that's the tallest
building in kiev
over there
yeah it feels like southern california
taking a little break guys i got a fuel
up
got some cool places to bring us to
going to step into a little bit of
history and then
a beach situation in the city
so my goal isn't just to show you all
the rich parts
but it is to show you there this does
exist it's quite often the story that's
not
shown in ukraine that there are nice
places like this
it's small rich uh small middle
and uh majority uh getting by
in ukraine in general and keep the
capital in the center a bit different
as you can see
so this street is known as crochettic
also known as
turkish attic reason being there used to
be 11 flights a day
from istanbul and this is the number one
tourist street
in the city uh usually busy with people
usually with a scam or two some
musicians
street food not my favorite street
but still interesting to scope out
most tourists end up here for sure and
if you see this architecture here
it's all built in stalin's style
after world war ii uh this this was
pretty much rubble
and so it's built from the ground up and
uh the stalinistic way
this is the center of the city the
maidan and
where the revolution of dignity took
place
uh what is the netflix special it's
called um i'll leave it in here
i forget the name of it really
interesting this is where
some of the citizens ran up the hill
towards parliament
uh ma happened here and this just shows
you
how interesting the world is in the
respect that you know five years ago
super dangerous right here now
it's like this the same can be said for
other cities right like
parts of new york parts of other
american cities
in the last few months you wouldn't want
to spend time near uh
near the looting and before that was
fine it will be fine again
but the world is title conflict happens
and it goes
things change and not to be get get
caught up on the old
information you know people still think
ukraine is super dangerous to travel to
the country is technically at war uh
but unless something changed the last
day or two not one
ukrainian soldier has been killed in the
last month on the front line which is
very far from here which is very far
from the capital
um that doesn't discredit the trauma
that comes with
being in a conflict or anyone that's
involved with it
in it but i just want to drive home the
fact that
you know you've seen it today it's
pretty
it's pretty chill pretty calm pretty
cool
so we're going to go up and see some
history right now really
interesting event that happened in this
country uh
it tells a lot about the people here
and then off to a cool beach location
in the city okay guys this video got way
too long
so i split it into two videos continue
watching in part two